this is a piece of a mineral it's a
quartzite mineral and we're actually in
the Ethiopian Institute for the
Department of mineralogy
the central mineralogy lab where all of
the minerals from the country are
analyzed and their content is is noted
and this is a really good nice sample
the quartzite which is silicon dioxide
essentially based but inside this rather
large lump we can see some very nice
grains of pure gold
so Ethiopia is famous for production of
gold and this is a really nice sample
it's really fortunate to see it so you
can see circled in the red circle there
one two quite large chunks of gold so so
the gold grains embedded in the stones I
brought to this room they are cut and
then they're crushed in Mills to make a
very fine powder the gold is then
extracted or removed from the fine
powder by its mass with water then the
grains of gold are taken for analysis in
the laboratory and this is a very
important laboratory for a gold
producing country because it's where all
of the gold standards are really made
and where the analysis is carried out
for material which is either bought or
sold in the country today I've been
talking with Qatar who is the the expert
and the head of the of the gold analysis
and he's explained the process to me so
what we see on the bench here are a
whole range of different samples of
material that people have brought to the
laboratory for analysis there are some
from companies there are some from the
police so these are materials that have
been bought unknowingly as gold when in
fact they turned out to be something
very very far from gold in fact most of
them were brass so the analysis is very
very important because it actually tells
us the real value of the commodity
that's been brought or sold so for
instance one of these materials which
claims to be pure gold would be digested
in the laboratory by digesting the metal
or dissolving it in aqua regia we make a
very very dilute or a weak solution of
many many metals this is no good for
analysis because the analysis
is it's bothered by all of the other
metals in solution if we want to analyze
gold we have to separate all of the
other metals out so we do that by making
a coordination compound this is
chemistry and in this case we're
saturating it with chlorides so the
chloride itself with gold is extractable
into an organic medium something like
petrol and it leaves all of the other
metals behind in the water at the bottom
so we don't need to analyze for the
other metals gold is special why special
it is very beautiful this is one one
case and it cannot change it is it is it
is characters it is faith and it is
existence as longer even if you put in
water for a very long time and you can
store your money that will never change
and all the tokens are might be proud of
it I don't know thank you thank you for
having us and showing us these things
today ok thank you thank you yeah okay
thank you okay okay on short notice
hope your prejudice thank you very much